Dana Carvey has done it all now he's
going to stand-up special straight white
male 60 it's like a variety show in
other words it's a lot of sketches I do
Paul McCartney and John Lennon talking
for five minutes
no you playing off yourself John Lennon
from heaven asking Paul about Kanye West
whether is lyrics about well you know he
writes I like a chess thumper he writes
about how good he is you know remember
when you said we were as popular as
Jesus he thinks he is Jesus I've been
trying gets upset does he have a woman
who inspires him who does his very -
terrific girl named Kim Kardashian what
does she do pole watch the smash she
takes pictures of a bottom was a
Polaroid camera knows the baby
television in the future we are baby
televisions in a pocket and she takes
pictures of a bottom the whole family's
doing it one met one gentleman got so
frustrated he became a woman
so it's Paul explaining 2016 to John oh
that's great do they remember us Paul oh
yeah we outsold everyone with Eminem we
got outsold by a candy